I think it's the biggest irony of my
career that we're in the middle of a
pandemic but we're struggling to keep
staff pay and keep the doors open
kovat 19 has completely ravaged
hospitals across the country all across
the state rural hospitals are on the
brink of collapse to hospitals closing
for good leaving patients and doctors to
fend for themselves hospital
administrators are fearing shortages in
staffing in supplies and in cash the
Boston Consulting Group said in a recent
support report that during this pandemic
about one out of every five US hospital
systems is on the brink of insolvency
the longer this goes on and when I say
that I'm not talking about lunch or
quarters on the calendar
it's literally weeks because every week
that goes by it's that many more
hospitals that are gonna be closing and
so really is that urgent it's brought to
the fore the fragile nature of health
care and rural health care in particular
if you can't keep hospitals especially
in rural West Virginia rural America
then we've got no way to take care of
our citizens
this is Scott Graham I am the CEO of two
hospitals
two small rural hospitals and both of
those hospitals have been hit especially
hard by covin 19 this moved so quickly
that one day we were talking about our
plans to grow and develop our service
lines and literally the next day we were
talking about are we going to be able to
stay in business
both Three Rivers and North Valley
Hospital have been struggling to be
profitable
long before the coronavirus prior to all
of this Three Rivers hospital the one
located in Brewster Washington was
really struggling financially and has
been for many years probably two decades
some of that has to do with the fact
that it's located in a very sparsely
populated area so patient volumes are
pretty low and we rely on patient
volumes for the revenue that we get to
cover the cost of the care that we
provide a lot of hospitals in the US
have been in dire financial straits for
a while now we know that at least 30
hospitals entered bankruptcy last year
alone and that's just a continuation of
a trend that's been going on for several
years about a hundred and twenty or so
rural critical access hospitals have
closed since 2010 to understand why
hospitals are in so much trouble
you have to understand how they make
their money hospitals and physicians are
paid really by three primary payers
Medicaid Medicare and in commercial
insurance there's obviously patients who
pay for their own services but that's a
very small portion of how hospitals and
physicians are paid nearly 80% of
hospitals revenue is generated by high
margin specialized surgical procedures
the best example would be orthopedic
need knee elbows shoulders of total
joints those are typically called
elective procedures because it can
actually wait they don't need to be done
emergently we have general surgeons who
do a variety of different types of
surgical procedures from colonoscopies
to endoscopy x' to appendectomy x' and
those sorts of things and usually those
do well enough that they can make up the
difference for what our other services
don't once coded 19 hit those
money-making elective surgeries vanish'd
the search of kovat 19 in Southeast
Michigan is having a chilling effect on
the health systems non coronavirus
services the impact is leading to some
hospital staff members losing their jobs
both speaking for hospitals and also for
physicians it's obviously chaos there
have been rapid changes in the law in
the last four to five weeks since the
pandemic was declared they have not been
allowed to do what they call elective
procedures so anything that can wait has
to wait compounding the problem of no
more elective procedures our patients
without Kovan 19 avoiding hospitals
altogether when I hear across the board
from my hospital clients around the
country because we're the national
practice is that the number of patients
that are in their Hospital is at least
one half if not greater than what it
normally is at this time of the year and
if a hospital closes in an urban area it
might be difficult for the community but
not a catastrophe the same can't be said
for hospitals in rural areas the
hospital has a symbiotic relationship
with the community we not only provide
care and very much needed care we not
only save lives every day but we provide
a livelihood for many of the folks who
live and work in these communities we
employ nurses and doctors and surgery
techs and housekeepers and dietary folks
and they all live in these communities
and contribute to the economy and were
we to no longer be able to exist there
would be a large gaping hole in the
economy here
Okanagan County hospitals are not just
one of the most important health care
providers in America they're also one of
the largest employers in America so with
all these hospitals on the brink of
insolvency the government had to step in
we haven't seen that flood of bankruptcy
filings that may come yet and in part
that's because the government recently
passed this multi trillion dollar
stimulus bill to 2.2 trillion dollar
cares Act is comprehensive and
absolutely needed a significant amount
of this money will go to the hospitals
and hotspots well a portion of it will
reimburse hospitals for the cost of
treating uninsured patients and for the
coronavirus there was about a hundred
billion dollars allotted to hospitals
across the country we're very grateful
that the cares Act was passed and it has
provided some initial initial help
though it is not sufficient to get us
through this Three Rivers hospital got
about three hundred and seven thousand
dollars from the cares money and that
will give us nearly a month's worth of
cash on hand it really is just a
band-aid right now for the greater
financial crisis that's hidden health
care industry so while the first round
of federal aid has helped the problem is
far from being solved hospitals are
getting an additional seventy five
billion dollars as part of the latest
bailout package approved by Congress on
April 23rd but it still might not be
enough more government aid could be
needed as the pandemic continues this
really affects every physician every
dentist every healthcare professional in
the country I think what this is how
people realize is even hospitals may not
be there if we don't take care to help
them be there obviously we're going to
need more and we hope the dev support
continues but actually it's it's given
me a lot of hope
you